hey everyone what's going on we are back
talking about cameras once again at the
canon r3 this can be my long-term review
i did a first impressions would have put
a link right here but back then i had
very minimal time with that camera i've
had this in my hand for the past few
weeks over the christmas holidays i've
shot thousands of photos so we're gonna
talk about how good this camera is and
if this is the right camera for you
let's talk about it right now
[Music]
talking about the r3 i know shipments
are delayed i know a lot of you are
waiting patiently for this camera and it
may be months before it comes to your
local camera shop or online so hopefully
this video will uh give you a little
relief in the meantime a big thanks to
ken and singapore for allowing us to
test drive this camera uh having said
that these are my thoughts and my
thoughts only now if you don't have time
to watch this entire video let me just
break it down to you
this is my favorite canon camera to date
i didn't think it was going to be
because i absolutely love the r5 and the
1d x3 and i love a larger form factor
camera i've always have
i love having that vertical grip when i
need it or just the normal grip but i
love just the feel of these sports
cameras that can just go through any
kind of terrain or weather and you know
it's going to be fine and this camera
has exceeded my expectations from it now
i did have a initial hands-on briefly
when it was first announced but i did
have it like other reviewers had it so
to actually get this in my hands and
shoot it for the past few weeks has been
very enlightening
photography up to 30 frames per second
autofocus is fast it's precise i mean
for the most part there will be some
things i'll talk about in just a bit but
i would say that
this is around 95 of the shots that i
want to get i'm gonna get with this
camera battery life is great even when
shooting video i have shot a lot of
video 4k high quality video here on the
channel we'll put uh some samples for
you right here spiderman no way home
review that was shot on this and others
as well and the output is fantastic i
didn't really dabble in the 6k because
honestly
why do i need to dabble with 6k 4k high
quality is so good
i don't need to go 6k i'm already
killing my editors they're already
pissed off at me by giving them this
high these like gigabytes of files
i don't want to like have them not want
to edit any of my videos by going 6k you
know what i mean but i will say the
image quality is there
camera doesn't overheat
and i push this because i talk a lot as
you see in this video i talk a lot and
these give you these reviews so if
anyone's going to overheat a camera
especially in the the heat of singapore
it will be me doesn't overheat image
quality coming out of photos fantastic
sharp 24 megapixels you're probably
thinking but 24 is very low nowadays
right it's 20 21. we've got 45 when the
z9 we've got you know 50 from the alpha
one how does this compare to be honest
with you this camera punches way above
its clear weight class at 24 megapixels
as a matter of fact it resolves more
like a 30 megapixel camera because of
the lens and the sensor so i was really
impressed by the image quality you're
going to see some of the images we'll be
showing samples as well and i'll be
going in lightroom right after this
little uh talking spiel so
that's my thoughts of a nutshell of the
r3 as a matter of fact i don't even know
what canon's going to do with a rumor r1
because this camera is that good anyway
let's go into lightroom right now and
let me show you images taken with the
canon r3
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if you leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.co
alright guys we are now in lightroom
taking look at images from the canon r3
the lenses used are the rf51.2 the rf
100 macro and the rf 70 to 200 f 2.8
let's get into some macro shots i love
this lens by the way the 100 macro i
really enjoyed using it it's not just
for macro you can use it for portraiture
as well and i'll show you some samples
in just a bit but here's this elderly
lady that was in this small shop in
chinatown and all they do is paint these
these figurines and statuettes all day
long
now i know obviously they have some
religious um
importance to them i don't know exactly
what they are but nonetheless very very
beautiful but let's just zoom in on her
real quick to see the detail and how
sharp this lens is as well as with the
camera sensor on this now it's a 24
megapixel sensor as mentioned before and
it does not resolve like a 24 megapixel
camera at all compared with the rf
lenses and the sensor i'm thinking
around 30 plus but look at the detail
right here on this look at this you can
see the skin texture here her glasses
the focus that's in this image and look
at the fall off on this i mean it's
absolutely beautiful this is a 100
millimeter macro f 2.8 this is before
edit and here's after edit before edit
and after edit now edits our personal
preference you may like or dislike but
it's just to show you what you can do
with the image somewhat now let's look
at another uh macro shot here
actually not well i'd say you know i
won't say macro but i will say that it's
more of a
portraiture pseudo macro shot anyway
let's get into this a little bit here as
we can see the detail in the skin right
here now there is some noise creeping in
on this uh this is iso 2500
one over three twentieths of a second i
really wanted a steady shot i probably
could have brought down the shutter
speed a little bit more
but uh i wanted her to be steady so i
could capture that moment a little bit
so yeah look at that absolutely
beautiful and the iso even at 2500 is
very usable throw this in topaz de noise
and it's an absolutely clean image
here's another macro shot here actually
of the brush on the statue i just kind
of give you a close-up of what it looks
like here iso 1000 100 millimeters at up
2.8 one over three twentieths of a
second
and
look at the detail that we're seeing on
this imagine if this was at iso 100 how
sharp this would be
right so this gives you an idea of the
performance of this camera and this lens
uh i'm very very happy with what i'm
seeing with this macro and then i'll
show you some other shots with macro
lens here look at this uh
this flower and inside of it look at the
detail on this now this is actually the
lower iso iso 800 at one over one
hundredths of a second still look at the
detail in the capture and what it can
capture in this absolutely
beautiful
all right let's move on to some sports
shots here because i'm sure a lot of you
who are using this camera is going to be
using it for sports not just for still
photography now this is primarily shot
with the rf51.2
and we're gonna go through some
sequences here for you because
i did find the focusing to be absolutely
fantastic but at times it was a little
bit challenging case in point um let's
go through here first so in a situation
like this uh
the camera would at times would want to
focus on the guy in the back which i did
not want so i had to manually override
it and focus on the gentleman right here
closest to the camera now again because
this is a fighting scene there's a lot
of movement it's very difficult for
cameras to always nail focus like this
or allow the algorithm or the ai to take
over so sometimes as a photographer
you're gonna have to override that
that's what i did and i'm happy with the
output of it look at this absolutely
beautiful great shot on that now we the
film camera was on the far left right
over here so when you see it in the film
it'll look like he knocks him right in
the face but of course
i was in this park because i wanted to
capture both subjects in the frame so as
you can see you know film fighting isn't
actually that real all the time but you
know they do hit each other once in a
while i'll show you another uh series in
just a sec
let's take a look at this set uh
this real quick here
so we're gonna run through this
look at this uppercut shot
now he did actually touch his chin
there's blood in his mouth it spurts out
[Music]
and it just nailed focus look at that
shot money shot right there
the blood spurting out of his mouth
fake blood of course
and yeah
really really happy with that
now with this situation again the camera
was going to focus on this guy right
here while he's doing the punching i
wanted to be focused on him so i had to
manually override it as i mentioned this
is one of the caveats with the
autofocusing system that i did find
is that at least in the settings that i
have maybe there is something that i
don't know of yet but you cannot you
know when it's on eye tracking or face
tracking it's it just detects the person
closest to the camera what it thinks
should be in focus and there's not an
option like an arrow option to like you
know i want this person versus that
person especially if there's multiple
people in the shot at least in my
experience if i am incorrect please
correct me in the comment section below
but that's what i was uh coming across
okay here's uh some still shots here
with this this camera here of course
this is all fake all makeup movie magic
but again look at the detail on this and
let's just go over some of the specs on
this iso 1250 50 millimeters at f 1.2
one over four hundredths of a second i
probably could have slowed down the
shutter speed on this but again this was
we're shooting in and out we're running
around so i was sort of letting the
camera take it uh you know dictate what
i wanted to do and here we are and but
again very very happy with the quality
of image even at iso 1250 this is very
usable here's another shot here
focusing on this look at the detail on
that iso 5000 very usable at iso 5000
guys one over one thousandths of a
second on this he was going in for
punches and of course he was blocking it
but look at the detail that we're
capturing here uh again throw this into
opacity noise you are golden
all right let's uh look at this shot
here as well this is the chokehold
happening here on the ground
and you can see just the the detail in
the face right here all the blood
the swollen eye the mouthpiece
got the forearm right here i mean just
visceral
look at the settings right here real
quick iso 1000 one over 400 of a second
absolutely awesome okay let's look at
some other macro shots here of jewelry
if you're going to do some still shots
this is of a gucci watch at a very uh
exclusive couture jewelry exhibition and
i wanted to capture this tobiyon
movement here real quick and look at the
detail that we're able to capture with
this guys
as i mentioned before and i'll say it a
few times throughout this video the 24
megapixels i was a little bit worried on
this do not be this camera does resolve
much higher than 24 megapixels in my
personal opinion and this showcases it
as well
so very happy with that
here's a
beautiful diamond encrusted watch here
i don't want to know how much this is
it
has more zeros than i have in my bank
account so we won't even go there but
nonetheless it's an absolutely beautiful
watch and the detail that this macro
lens was able to capture with the r3 i'm
very happy and this is iso 2000
i'm very very happy with the quality of
the image quality coming out of this
camera let's look at some other portrait
shots here this was taken during filming
as well
iso 320 70 millimeters at 3.2 this is
with the 70 to 200 f 2.8 fantastic lens
guys i mean this is a great lens for the
rf mount especially want some
versatility i highly recommend it and at
a 3.2 2.8 you can get some nice falloff
in the background that's really going to
you know separate your subject here and
this is a shot of me actually with the
actor in the film uh we're doing a fight
sequence here and this is a little bit
uh creeped up in terms of iso
performance i think around 10 000 with
this i was handing the camera to
somebody else and they were just firing
away but even in iso 10000 i mean you're
going to see some you know some grain
happening here but very usable image
once again anyway guys as shown by the
images here the output out of this
camera system is absolutely fantastic
i'm really happy with the performance
the iso performance is really good the
focusing is fantastic there's so much
you can do with this camera system that
i think
once you start really working with it
you're gonna really find that it is a
special camera it's gonna take some time
i mean even me having it over the past
few weeks is not long enough to master
this camera to become one with it and i
think if i had it for months i would
really understand the nuances in the
settings because there's so much inside
of it anyway let's go to my final
thoughts on the r3
so as you saw in lightroom the image
quality coming out of this camera paired
with these rf lenses is absolutely
fantastic it punches way above 24
megapixels as i mentioned my personal
opinion it feels more like a 30 plus
megapixel camera system which is great
it gives you some cropping power if you
need it but i'm really impressed with
the video coming out of this the auto
focus and video is fantastic as well
but so there are some issues with this
camera system that i do want to point
out because not all is perfect with it
even as as much as i like it there are
some small caveats first and foremost it
is going to be the flip out rotatable
display on this i love it i'm glad we
have it however it doesn't actually line
up correctly when you flip out and turn
down so you're actually going to get it
a little bit on an angle so if you want
to shoot a low shot and you're looking
to get your horizon level it might throw
you off a little bit it's not a deal
breaker but it is something to take note
of also the brightness on the display
isn't the brightest out there so if
you're in bright harsh sunlight you may
find yourself uh having to look at that
viewfinder just to double check that
your shot is lined up or in focus
because it does have a little bit of a
cap when it comes to that brightness
level outside let's talk about another
feature of this camera which is a little
bit hit miss for me that's eye control
now we did see this with the the initial
eye control was with the eos 3 back in
the day and it worked quite well for the
film camera back then but it's brought
here into the r3 and in my initial
impressions i had a hard time
calibrating it but then i watched other
reviewers and they were saying that it
was so good and helps them focus and i'm
like what am i missing so i tried it
again recalibrated this time with the
you know the production firmware it
works well calibration worked relatively
easy
and it's still not accurate for me now
it could be my eyes or whatever the case
may be but i'll look at something and
that dot will be floating there but
i still got to focus and then if it's
not what i want to focus on i got to
move the joystick i got to move the
focusing point to it's just it's
convoluted and i get the technology and
i think there's a lot of benefit to this
technology coming in the future but i
think right now
it's still an infancy stage and i would
say personally that if you're using this
for work
and you're capturing sports or wildlife
and you need that person or subject or
animal to be in focus and your job
depends on it i wouldn't recommend using
eye control in that regard stick with
what you know the auto focusing system
is really good in this camera you really
don't need eye control for that matter
the ai that they build in these things
is you know
it does a much better job than me
looking at that that that point and this
floating little circle going around it's
very frustrating in that regard the
buttons on the back of this area now it
does remind me a lot of the one dx3
however near the top part where your
thumb is going to rest you've got a
record button you've got your af on kind
of touch button here you've got your
joystick you've got the switch that goes
from video to photo mode which is great
but it's all right there with your thumb
so sometimes you can actually
accidentally press the wrong button
this has happened to me a few times
which does make it a little bit of a
stickler and i do wish that uh there was
a little bit more space between these
buttons now again i've had this for
about a few weeks if i had it for months
i probably would memorize where
everything is at but it is something to
take note of speaking of those autofocus
buttons with the joystick and that touch
button there that we have from the 1dx
carried over let's talk about the auto
focusing points on this this is a great
camera for auto focusing it locks on eye
tracking is fantastic all that is really
good however you don't have the option
at least from what i can find is to
choose which subject you want to choose
like you know focus on if it's two or
three people in a frame it will choose
the person closest to the camera so in
that case you're gonna have to manually
override the system and change your auto
focusing uh option to something a little
bit more manual like a single point or
you know very various point autofocus
and then move it over to capture that
person maybe there's a setting that i'm
missing but i couldn't seem to find it
in my experience with this camera but
that was something that i wish it was
there that i did see in other camera
systems where it's like an arrow and you
can just move left or right and select
which person you want to focus not a
deal breaker but it is something to take
note of now let's also talk about the
battery door on this camera system now i
don't usually complain about battery
doors for the most part but this one
because the camera feels so robust this
battery door feels a little bit of an
afterthought it feels a little bit like
it's uh the plastic quality is not as
good as the rest of the body i don't
want to say it feels cheap but it does
feel a little bit
neither here nor there and there are a
couple times where i didn't lock it
correctly and it kind of just jut it out
i have to re-kind of reset it it didn't
break off or anything but it's something
to take note of you do have a lock you
have to kind of pull out and then open
but it doesn't you know i mean it
doesn't have that solid feel that you
would get out of your other let's say
your 1dx3 or
you know other pro body cameras i feel
this is just sort of an afterthought in
that regard let's talk about image
stabilization for a moment you know ibis
this camera's got it it's just like the
rfi which i feel is one of the better
ibis systems out there you know some
people would be a little bit
apprehensive using this camera for video
because they're going to be like well i
want a smaller camera but
having a larger camera does allow you to
have a much more stable shot when you're
shooting video now again i don't know if
i'll be vlogging with this and i don't
really have to vlog nowadays put it on a
tripod and just talk or i got zeno here
with me who's going to help me out but
uh
i think it works well and if you are
like a one-man operation let's say
you're shooting weddings you know
whatever the case may be you don't have
a gimbal but you still want to get those
steady shots i think having this extra
size of the camera with the ibis will
definitely help you out a lot versus
let's say an r5 or a smaller camera
system which can add you know just
camera shake because as a whole they're
smaller cameras so something we said
about having a pro body in that regard
let's also talk about ports really quick
on this camera because of course you
have all the professional ports you need
ethernet port headphone mic jack you
have your usbc
micro hdmi y canon micro hdmi this is a
big camera give us full size
but you have that there if you need it
but i don't use an external recorder for
this for the most part because i don't
need to this camera can record with the
you know the cfx press type b card up to
6k so raw so
i'm okay without it anyway
the usbc port i want to talk to you a
little bit about this because ken is
stating that you can somewhat charge the
camera
with
the usbc port
depending on the charger now if you're
running into some issues of what charger
to use i'll just give you what i've used
that is the xiaomi charger that comes
with the phone you can buy them in the
shop as well order them online
like 69 watts or 120 watt they're about
you can charge the camera via that way
now if you want to keep the battery
charged
with the usb-c uh cable as you're
recording video
it kind of doesn't really work that well
from my experience i tried it with those
chargers it charges the camera but
it will give you enough juice to keep
going but
if you're gonna run flat you're gonna
run flat so hopefully canada can improve
this in a firmware update to uh allow
this camera to be charged while
recording that would be ideal
however speaking about all these points
the big point for me on this camera
where i think it's gonna be very
difficult for a lot of people to say yes
or no to is going to be the price
of the r3 this is competing with the
likes of the sony alpha one the nikon z9
these are 45 50 megapixel cameras
respectively going up to 30 frames per
second you know 8k video recording yada
yada
this
is not at that level it's close
but it's priced at that level
and this makes it a very difficult uh
decision for a lot of buyers out there
do we just go for the r5 right now which
is on special because here in singapore
this camera is going around 8 700
singapore dollars that's right in line
with the alpha one that is above the z9
but the r5 is around five to six
thousand depending on what camera shop
you go to and what deals available so
how does this come into play and that's
really where it's it's perplexing is i
feel in my personal opinion canon has
overpriced this camera compared to the
competition i feel this is around six to
seven thousand singapore dollars which
would be about you know
four thousand five to
five thousand five usd or you know
maybe this would be a much more
competitive price range i know they want
to keep it comparable to the one dx3
because they don't want to you know
alienate the 1dx3 of course that is
their flagship camera but canon's got to
make a decision on this because they
can't have it all and i know those
people who ordered this camera but
it's going to make a lot of people think
twice
do i
get the r3 because if the r3 is price of
this what is the r1 going to be priced
at 12 000 10 000
i mean i'm not taking anything away from
the technology the canon's offering
but that's a lot of coin for a camera
okay again i'm speaking in singapore
dollars mind you but
this is very expensive but even for r5
for photography's sake i mean 20 frames
per second electronic shutter yeah it's
not as good as this one but can it get
the job done
you know it's going to save you a couple
thousand that's a lens
so i don't know anyway food for thought
on that let me know in the comment
section below if you agree with me or
disagree with me on the price of that
but outside of this i've really enjoyed
the r3 i just really like this camera i
say this a lot but it's gonna be sad to
give this back to canon but it does have
to go back to them but
i just love what the output i'm getting
out of it the colors the image quality
and i love the feature set and it's a
camera that i could spend a long time
using
uh to get to know but uh yeah it is what
it is anyway those are my thoughts on
the r3 let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below do you agree with
me on the r3 are there any questions you
have i'll try to answer those for you
with that guys take care stay safe
subscribe to this channel like this
video and i'll chat to you soon take
care
[Music]
you